hello everybody welcome back to let's
play killing it all set I'm still a
little drunk um ha ha ha ha Oh sailors
I love sailors we just got done burger
oh god that's loud we just got done
recording drunk minecraft and I remember
that I didn't record anything for
tomorrow today are you guys so we're
gonna play some killing it out that
secret lord ra-el acting ha ha ha
ah hell I'm talking about hey hello oh
this alright what do i what did I need I
need is something I'm in perfect health
what did I need I'm gonna get [ __ ] at
a good deal yeah I know right
uh wow you're really needle stings don't
yeah I do ok did not know that you could
find that much money around here uh-huh
yeah ok and all right that's enough I'll
save one for later
all right Thank You Boris okay back to
the scariness and as always have a nice
day I'm a nice day Oh God
Oh Oh make your way down surprised
hi yes I am the owner of dissing you
seem kind of bigoted I am responsible
for all the things yeah to see them
you're very naked but before you want to
kill me let me explain
you're still naked Lord Johannes as a
horrible disease ha ha and I trying to
find a potion
if I don't succeed you will die ah you
probably think
Jews thousands but you have to know no
air crash hundred huh conflict not
conflict that we have to avoid such a
situation okie-dokie go to johannes he
will explain it you explained it like
crap kill the owner with that all oh oh
you are so dying
yeah hahaha you Oh God I went to town on
that [ __ ]
ah true that what oh it was that it
sounded like a slender static sound
Baylor's yeah all right so I murdered
that [ __ ]
he probably deserved it I don't care if
thousands of dying I don't know if I
would have made the same decision if I
was sober but it's too late to think
about that now I make the choices that I
make you can't judge me come on
oh wait no huh click ah I stopped
drinking
ah this is Sam Adams blackberry witbier
it's very delicious
we ale brewed with blackberries and
spices and natural flavor added it's
good it's good smash anything back here
sailors sailors sailors get out of here
Baylor's sailors come on scare me
oh what's this on isn't look so bad oh
is it all scary oh no oh no oh that's
actually interesting whoop Oh like a
mouse jump Oh epic leap I know
Oh what is that that sounds like a
slender static noise up up up didn't
hurt it was this sailors ma cv flu yeah
Oh like a mouse
what's that a water monster and don't
scare me up yeah
favors love me some sailors huh yeah
well yeah how was that oh I don't see
any more sailors around there that's at
the it OOP oh no don't go that way Oh
like a boss high kicks what are you
doing get out of here ah no I meant it
jump
got it nailed it yeah
Clegg is this place about to fill up
with water
what the hell oh I'll go through that
seems good to me Mike and I can't go
through that all right so don't know
what we're like wah all move man to
quote Bob Oh No thank you have you man
good god no way no give me the phone is
off ha ha ha well the point of that what
was the point of that oh come on not
fair
give me oh god I love this custom story
so much I hate you hate you [ __ ]
I like how you know that's really cool
that he has these areas that are just
dedicated to skiers it's really really
really cool I like that a lot about this
oh hello
all right that guy how you doing nope
uh-uh love oh that's that door again no
biggie we got it we got it I might like
am I going wait what
Oh
oh wait wha wha what what oh oh oh
Wham
did I get it wait that can't be right
I can't get through there I had to do
what is it a diet did you do what did I
did I did to do well that's not fair how
does that help me did I just break it I
I think I broke it
oh oh oh well what the hell am I
supposed to do then
what am I going to do
hey let me try resetting the level I
can't go back out damn it I might have
broke did it a lot maybe there's a key
or something that I missed probably
probably probably oh no nothing it was
nothing
get out my way at home you're a hole Oh
what up oh right there whoops I probably
still [ __ ] shut up we all got problems
don't need to be yelling at me done ah
what am I supposed to use this pipe for
I don't even know
I'm just running in circles but I got
the pipe whatever that means I got it
no hello iron soldiers okay so I got
this now I go over here and I don't go
that way and I have an iron pipe which
means what no uh-uh
okay so I uh Oh what the hell
I did break it ah fudge nutters fudge I
got a reload hang on a we were up well
I'm not going anywhere you can all just
watch me ah ah fudge maybe this will
work
I don't know I don't know why this is
gonna put me ah I screwed up so bad oh
I'm an idiot I'm an idiot I'm a giant
it's on now I get to kill the guy again
yeah I hope you buy this time clunk what
the foot deal I know right Boris Huang
hua come on what's up dings deal alright
screw everything else just oil for me
alright so hungry to use it
not you guys Tim I say no time alone
yeah I'm looking everybody down Rosalyn
rice I love you I am the owner of digit
Jess I am responsible for all the things
dear don't eat we will do but before you
want Lorch everybody with me Oh
here you know hundreds can hear you
this is not an oral call it is obvious
that we have to avoid such a situation
go to Johannes he will explain it
Oh God he'll explain shorter I'm gonna
kill you just cuz I had to listen to
that again good god you are enjoying
please die I did I cut him into pieces
with a dagger if anyone knows anything
about knives that's probably really
impressive click all right let's go like
a mouse I said like a mouse and watch
this sick move I got right here you
ready for this oh yeah you ready for
this stick move hey on it's gonna be
awesome
hey yeah yeah [ __ ] the thalers group
what the hell yeah did you see that wait
where's the door I don't know where the
doors there it is aw sick move how
I don't know what's wrong with me
let's go going oh I'm so slow I know
which way to go
can't beat me I'm a man [ __ ] you yeah I
didn't even see you
don't kill me are you big baby
ha ha ha ha
oh you guys ah got it no I just run down
here let go
bow oh I healed ha ha I magically healed
up yeah I like it I like you too hard
hi poof
BAM it's funny the second time cuz I
know what's happening oh god no I can't
do this for every episode if you're
questioning that that would be
impossible
my liver wood is load yeah I miss ha
yeah hello
now alright now that didn't take too
long right back to where we was where no
wait we're right back to where we were
like oh wow
BAM yeah so bye dear sailors but the
sailors thalers 25 bail is all yes ha ha
it's a Stefano shine ha ha ha
I don't normally acknowledge these cuz
it's not my bit but ha ha that's really
cool I'm really cool I just got remade
then finally I just gotta admit I do
have the deepest respect it might mother
pick this up or something oh no probably
not it's a mini box I'm more impressed
with this box actually you didn't end up
in a box like I said before I have the
greatest respect for Pete
by what he does so I I didn't no way I
have bad blood about that
hey God picked up so I I don't like when
people back beautify he's a good guy if
I met him in real life we Boop we're
probably good friends I bet that but
then then again like ever shut up
everybody I mean real life I'm good
friends with so anyway I'm all out of
time so thank you so much for watching
click the annotation more videos that
I've done that as always I'll see you
it's actually bye bye